As you can see, not all data makes the jump correctly from Twinmotion to Unreal.
Another example of this is in the form of the animated doors.
They are animated in Twinmotion as you get close to them, but that functionality has disappeared with the transfer to UE5.
The rotators are still in place acting as hinges, as are the hierarchies, but not the animation.
The good news is that you can replicate the effect in UE5 with the help of a simple blueprint.
Adjust your view outside the doors on the upper floor. Also set Play Mode to activate from the current camera location.
In the Theater folder in the Content Browser, create a BP for Blueprint subfolder.
In it, create a new actor blueprint and name it DoorOpen. Double-click the blueprint to edit it.
Select one of the doors and browse to the asset in the Content Browser.
Add a new Static Mesh component to the blueprint.
Because the door asset is selected in the Content Browser, it will be automatically added to the Blueprint viewport.
Simplify the name of the Static Mesh component in the blueprint as Door.
Select the default scene root entry and add Child Actor.
This will act as a non-renderable null object and will be used as a hinge for the door.
In fact, name it Hinge.
Adjust the position of the door so that its right side is aligned with the hinge at 0,0,0.
Use a Snap value of 1cm for better control.
Parent the door to the hinge.
Next, you need a trigger box.
Select the default scene root again and add a Box Collision component.
Name it Trigger.
Adjust its position and Extents to match the door.
And also make sure it extends enough in the Y direction to allow a fair distance to trigger it as you step in.
In the Event Graph tab, delete all existing nodes, you won't need them.
Select the Trigger component and go lower in the Details panel.
Click the On Component Begin Overlap and On Component End Overlap events.
This will add nodes where you can define what happens when you step in or out of the trigger volume.
Drag the Hinge component into the working area, and add Set Relative Rotation to it with a 90 degree Z rotation angle.
Connect the action to the Begin Overlap event.
This will set the door to rotate 90 degrees when you step into the volume.
Compile and save, and then drag an instance of the blueprint to the scene to test the results.
Test the scene in Play mode.
At this stage, the door opens with a snap and remains open.
You could expand on the blueprint by duplicating nodes and resetting the rotation angle to 0 as you end the overlap.
To duplicate nodes, select them and then press Ctrl-D.
Compile and save.
The effect works but the snapping is bothersome.
You need a smoother rotation.
To create a smoother rotation, add a Timeline node.
Rewire the connections to the door on Begin Overlap, and double-click the Timeline node to edit it.
Add a float track named Door Opening.
Here we'll define an animation curve to smoothly open the door between two angle values.
With a right-click, add two keyframes to the curve.
Select them both and set them to Auto Tangents.
This will add ease-in, ease-out effects to the door opening and closing.
Set the first key at a time position of 0 with a value of 0.
This means that the door is closed before you get into the trigger volume.
Set the second key to a time position of 2, as in 2 seconds, and a value of 110.
This essentially means that it'll take 2 seconds for the door to rotate 110 degrees.
Use the Zoom buttons on the toolbar to view the extents of the curve.
Go back to the event graph when done and note the new door opening pin representing the new timeline curve.
Right-click the new rotation track in the Set Relative Rotation event and split the structure pin.
This separates the Vector3 XYZ rotation and separate float tracks.
Wire the door opening curve to the Z Relative Rotation of the hinge.
To reverse the action of the door, you only need to wire the On Component End overlap node to the reverse pin of the timeline.
You can delete any excess nodes at this time.
Compile and save the blueprint, then test your work.
The door should be behaving much better now.
Delete the test instance when done.
Next, you will replace the Twinmotion doors with the blueprint.
Start with the upper door on the right as viewed from the bridge.
It is actually made of two actors, a mesh door and a non-renderable rotator.
You won't need the door at all as the blueprint you have defined already contains a duplicate, so go ahead and delete it.
Select the remaining rotator actor.
Make sure the blueprint is also selected in the Content Browser.
Right-click the selected actor in the Outliner and replace it with the blueprint.
Test your work.
Note that the door is swinging to the incorrect side.
Arguably the easiest way to fix this is by setting its Y scale to minus 1.
This will reverse the swing.
Repeat the procedure with the left door.
This one will swing correctly and does not require Y scale adjustments.
Repeat the procedure for the doors at the ground level.
These will require slight adjustments to their X scale as well, as they are a little wider.
A value of 1.35 should work well.
You can now use the doors to get in and out of the building.
Save your work before moving on.